todos
[Música]
hola hoy en science lic las simetrías
del universo
las leyes que rigen nuestro universo
pueden parecer complejas y numerosas
conservación de la energía principio de
acción reacción relatividad general
modelo estándar de partículas etcétera
sin embargo toda esta complejidad surge
de un concepto más profundo y refinado
del que todas estas leyes no son más que
consecuencias las simetrías
en matemáticas una simetría es una
transformación que no modifica un objeto
una esfera por ejemplo tiene una
simetría rotacional se puede girar
alrededor de ella cambiar su orientación
y permanece igual
una cuerda infinita tiene simetría de
traslación se puede desplazar a lo largo
de la cuerda y ésta sigue siendo la
misma
también resulta que el propio universo
puede tener simetrías una simetría del
universo es una transformación que no
afecta a las leyes de la física
para entenderlo imaginemos un universo
vacío en el que realizamos un sencillo
experimento arrojamos una pelota una vez
soltado sigue avanzando en línea recta a
velocidad constante
ahora imaginemos que nos movemos en el
universo y que realizamos el mismo
experimento en otro lugar aquí también
observamos que la pelota continúa línea
recta a velocidad constante se comporta
de la misma manera las leyes de la
física que la pelota sigue en uno y otro
lugar no han cambiado
este universo obedece a una simetría de
traslación si uno se desplaza en dicho
universo y realiza experimento en otro
lugar el resultado es el mismo
este universo obedece también a una
simetría de rotación se podría haber
girado cambiado de orientación y el
resultado habría sido el mismo
por último este universo también es
simétrico respecto al tiempo podríamos
haber esperado y haber lanzado la pelota
un poco más tarde las leyes de la física
no cambian entre un momento y otro
el hecho de que el universo cumpla con
simetrías y que las leyes de la física
sigan siendo las mismas después de
ciertas transformaciones impone
restricciones al comportamiento de los
objetos para explicarlo tomemos nuestro
universo vacío y tiremos la pelota
una vez lanzada la pelota adquiere
movimiento hacia adelante y en el
momento siguiente está ligeramente más
lejos ha cambiado de posición
pero si suponemos que el universo es
simétrico de traslación que las leyes de
la física siguen siendo las mismas
cuando cambiamos de posición entonces la
situación es equivalente al al instante
anterior la pelota se ha desplazado pero
las leyes de la física siguen siendo las
mismas allí y por tanto en cada instante
se moverá de la misma manera si las
leyes de la física son invariables de
traslación la simetría obliga la pelota
a conservar su movimiento lo que explica
por qué traza una línea recta a
velocidad constante
del mismo modo si un objeto gira sobre
sí mismo y suponiendo esta vez que las
leyes de la física son simétricas de
rotación justo después la situación es
equivalente y la simetría impondrá por
lo tanto que el objeto conserve su
rotación
así para que cada simetría el universo
sea respetada se impone la conservación
de una magnitud la conservación de la
cantidad de movimiento para las
traslaciones del momento cinético para
las rotaciones y de la energía para la
simetría temporal
este principio se llama teorema de nader
cada simetría al universo impone la
conservación de una magnitud en el
transcurso del tiempo
el teorema de no haber también se aplica
contenido del universo y en particular a
los campos cuánticos que constituyen la
propia materia
un campo cuántico también puede
presentar simetrías el campo de los
electrones por ejemplo está formado por
números complejos y las leyes de la
física que describen a los electrones no
cambian cuando todos estos números
complejos se desplazan al mismo tiempo
para entenderlo imaginemos que estamos
midiendo la altura de un avión en la
tierra para expresar la altura del avión
debemos fijar un punto de referencia por
ejemplo el nivel del mar
estableciendo esta referencia podemos
describir la altura mediante un número
pero esta elección de referencia es
arbitraria ya que podríamos haber
elegido otro punto y habríamos medido
valores diferentes pero la realidad
física no ha cambiado la misma situación
puede describirse de forma diferente
según el punto de referencia escogido
[Música]
del mismo modo para el campo de
electrones se puede variar el punto de
referencia con una rotación de la fase
de números complejos sin que ello afecte
a la situación física que se describe
este cambio de referencia constituye una
simetría y según el teorema en louder
esta simetría impone también la
conservación de una magnitud se trata de
la carga eléctrica
las leyes de conservación como por
ejemplo la conservación de la energía o
de la carga eléctrica no son por lo
tanto fundamentales es solo cuando el
universo posee una simetría subyacente
que para hacer cumplida esta simetría
requiere la conservación de una magnitud
[Música]
el principio de acción-reacción por
ejemplo que traduce la conservación de
la cantidad de movimiento cuando dos
objetos se separan es sólo una
consecuencia de la simetría de
traslación
si un objeto se mueve en una dirección
el otro debe moverse en la dirección
contraria gracias a esta simetría los
cohetes pueden despegar hacia arriba
expulsando materia hacia abajo
[Música]
surge entonces un problema a diferencia
del caso simplificado de un universo
vacío nuestro universo actual no parece
ser completamente simétrico en una
escala de miles de millones de años por
ejemplo el universo se dilata por lo que
no es perfectamente simétrico con
respecto al tiempo en consecuencia a
gran escala la energía en el universo no
se conserva la luz por ejemplo va
perdiendo gradualmente energía ya que su
longitud de onda se extiende a medida
que el universo se expande
el universo tampoco es perfectamente
simétrico de traslación contiene
estrellas y planetas por lo que a esta
escala no es igual en todas partes así
cuando un objeto cae su momento
generalmente no se conserva
en la tierra por ejemplo una manzana
cada hacia abajo y se acelera su
movimiento cambia con el tiempo ya que
la situación no es simétrica
[Música]
a primera vista nuestro universo no
parece respetar las simetrías peor aún
las leyes de la física parecen diferir
según el marco de referencia desde que
observamos al dejar caer una bola en el
interior de una centrifugadora si
observamos desde el exterior la bola
parece conservar su movimiento pero si
observamos desde el interior este no se
conserva sino que se acelera hacia la
superficie
como se explica que la pelota se
comporte de forma diferente en principio
las leyes de la física son absolutas si
queremos una buena descripción de
nuestro universo querríamos que todos
los objetos sea cual sea nuestro punto
de vista obedecieran siempre las mismas
leyes
sin embargo el comportamiento de la
pelota es distinto
[Música]
para resolver este problema y
restablecer el carácter absoluto de las
leyes de la física es decir que la
pelota se describa con las mismas leyes
será necesario añadir un nuevo elemento
a nuestra descripción
retomemos la analogía anterior midiendo
la altura de un avión el avión se mueve
en línea recta y si tomamos como
referencia el nivel del mar medimos una
altura constante que dibuja una línea
recta
sin embargo imaginemos ahora que tomamos
como referencia la superficie de la
tierra
esta vez debido a las montañas medimos
una altura que varía con el tiempo como
si el avión se moviera en zigzag
tomando como referencia a la superficie
de la tierra
el comportamiento del avión parece ahora
diferente sin embargo la situación no ha
cambiado el avión se mueve en línea
recta como podemos explicar el hecho de
que la altura el avión varía con el
tiempo mientras se mueve en línea recta
para resolver esta paradoja es necesario
introducir un campo de fuerza que empuje
el plano hacia arriba o hacia abajo
según el nivel de referencia elegido
al pasar de un nivel de referencia a
otro del nivel del mar al nivel de la
superficie terrestre es necesario añadir
este campo de fuerza para tener en
cuenta adecuadamente el comportamiento
del avión
[Música]
si volvemos al ejemplo de la pelota la
centrifugadora la situación es
exactamente la misma al pasar de un
punto de vista a otro la pelota parece
obedecer a leyes diferentes y es
necesario añadir algún tipo de campo de
fuerza a nuestra descripción se trata de
las llamadas fuerzas de inercia y en
particular la fuerza centrífuga y la
fuerza de coriolis al añadir estas
fuerzas iniciales restauramos de
carácter absoluto de las leyes de la
física el comportamiento de la pelota
puede ahora entenderse muy bien en
cualquier marco de referencia siempre y
cuando añadamos este campo de fuerzas
que dependerá del punto de vista
la introducción de este tipo de campo de
fuerza subyacente es también lo que da
lugar al concepto de curvatura del
espacio-tiempo y a la teoría de la
relatividad general es una teoría muy
poderosa precisamente porque restablece
el carácter absoluto de las leyes de la
física
para añadir una nueva estructura
subyacente al universo la curvatura del
espacio-tiempo la relatividad general
permite describir el universo desde
cualquier punto de vista con las mismas
leyes las mismas ecuaciones
[Música]
sorprendentemente este razonamiento
añadir un campo para restaurar la imm
varianza de las leyes de la física es
también la base de todas las
interacciones fundamentales en la física
de partículas
hemos visto que el campo cuántico de los
electrones tiene una simetría cuando
desplazamos todos los números complejos
de la misma forma globalmente
pero si desplazamos las distintas partes
del campo de forma diferente lo que
equivale a elegir un nivel de referencia
en zigzag como la superficie de la
tierra las leyes que describen los
electrones parecen haber cambiado en
otras palabras este cambio de referencia
no es una simetría
si queremos restablecer el carácter
absoluto de las leyes de la física sea
cual sea el nivel de referencia que
elijamos debemos cambiar necesariamente
nuestra descripción debemos introducir
otra estructura subyacente una especie
de campo de fuerza con la que interactúa
el campo de electrones para explicar
este cambio de comportamiento
esta otra estructura es el llamado campo
electromagnético
contiene partículas que interactúan con
los electrones los fotones
[Música]
en cierto modo si dos objetos se repelen
por su carga eléctrica si no atravesamos
una silla a sentarnos y si la luz existe
en el universo es gracias a esta
simetría local se debe al hecho de poder
cambiar el nivel de referencia a los
números complejos y requiere la
existencia de un nuevo campo y de nuevas
partículas los fotones con los que
interactúan los electrones
[Música]
para concluir el estudio de las
simetrías del universo nos permite
comprender de forma más profunda el
origen de las leyes que lo rigen es
porque el universo tiene simetrías que
los objetos se contiene para respetar
estas simetrías o deseen leyes
la conservación de la energía o el
principio de acción-reacción son leyes
que los objetos solo respetan para
cumplir con la simetría subyacentes del
universo al considerar que las leyes de
la física deben ser absolutas que el
cambio del punto de vista del nivel de
referencia debe constituir una simetría
que no afecte la realidad física lo que
se conoce como simetría gauge deducimos
la presencia de nuevas estructuras en el
universo como la curvatura del
espacio-tiempo o el campo
electromagnético
[Música]
experimentalmente las simetrías también
revelan los misterios escondidos de la
materia midiendo ciertas propiedades de
las partículas y estudiando los
diagramas geométricos resultantes las
simetrías han permitido comprender que
los protones los neutrones y otros
bariones están formados por tres objetos
más pequeños que obedecen a una simetría
fundamental basada en el número tres los
quarks
también hay simetrías discretas
por ejemplo la inversión de la carga de
la dirección en el espacio y de la
dirección en el tiempo de todas las
partículas constituye una simetría
así una antipartícula puede
interpretarse como una partícula
ordinaria que retrocede en el tiempo
por último algunas teorías modernas a
una especulativas postulan que el
universo puede poseer una simetría aún
más profunda una simetría entre las
partículas de materia y las partículas
de interacción como si ambas obedecieran
las mismas leyes se trata de la
supersimetría
[Música]